Whoa, what are you listening to this for? Wait, who's talking? You know you're driving a 2024 Ford Escape with available Alexa built-in, so you can change the music. Oh yeah, Alexa, change station to 99.2. See? Purchase a 2024 Escape ST-Line all-wheel drive with TechPak at 3.49% APR for 72 months with down payment. That's just $267 bi-weekly, cash value of $40,294. Plus, eligible Ford owners get a $1,000 bonus. For details, visit your local Ford store or ford.ca.
哇，你听这个干什么？等等，谁在说话？你知道你开的是一辆配备了内置 Alexa 的 2024 款福特 Escape，所以你可以换音乐。哦对了，Alexa，把电台换到 99.2。看到了吧？购买配备 TechPak 的 2024 款 Escape ST-Line 全轮驱动版，年利率 3.49%，分 72 个月还清，需支付首付。双周还款仅需 267 美元，现金价值 40,294 美元。此外，符合条件的福特车主还可获得 1,000 美元的奖金。详情请咨询当地福特经销商或访问 ford.ca。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的说明。本集最初发布在 Casefile 的 Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上，作为给我们付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在稍微缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。
To receive these episodes early and ad free, you can support Casefile on your preferred platform. The three member Slayton family lived in a one story, two bedroom duplex off Brunel Parkway in the Florida city of Lakeland. Single mum Linda slept in one bedroom with her youngest son Tim in the other. Linda's oldest boy, 15-year-old Jeff, slept on a cot in the living room. It was early on Friday September 4 1981 when Jeff Slayton woke to a strange sound. It was the crackle of a police radio. Jeff quickly realised that several officers had gained
要提前且无广告地收听这些剧集，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。Slayton 一家三口住在佛罗里达州莱克兰市布鲁内尔大道旁的一栋单层双拼别墅里。单亲妈妈琳达睡在一个卧室里，她最小的儿子蒂姆睡在另一个卧室。琳达的大儿子，15 岁的杰夫，睡在客厅的一张行军床上。那是 1981 年 9 月 4 日星期五的清晨，杰夫·斯莱顿被一种奇怪的声音惊醒。那是警用无线电的噼啪声。杰夫很快意识到几名警察已经进入
access to his home and were quietly moving about. What's going on, he asked. Jeff was told to get dressed and go outside. He did so completely perplexed as to why the police were even there. so completely perplexed as to why the police were even there. The officers made sure he exited out the front door away from his mother's bedroom. Jeff wandered out into the morning light and was immediately taken aback. It seemed like every cop in Florida was standing outside his home, along with news crews and reporters. Jeff spotted his Auntie Judy among the crowd. She was crying. Judy told Jeff that his mother had been murdered. Shortly before Jeff woke up that day, Judy Butler arrived at the Slayton's apartment to have her regular Friday morning coffee with her older sister, Linda. The sisters lived in the same government-owned complex just three doors away from each other. Judy knocked on Linda's front door several times and waited.
了他的家，正在悄悄走动。他问，发生了什么事？杰夫被告知穿好衣服出去。他完全困惑，不知道警察为什么会在那里。警察确保他从前门离开，避开了他母亲的卧室。杰夫走到晨光中，立刻被眼前的景象惊呆了。似乎佛罗里达州所有的警察都站在他家门外，还有新闻摄制组和记者。杰夫在人群中发现了他的朱迪阿姨。她在哭。朱迪告诉杰夫，他的母亲被谋杀了。在那天杰夫醒来前不久，朱迪·巴特勒来到斯莱顿家，准备和她的大姐琳达一起喝她惯常的周五早晨咖啡。姐妹俩住在同一个政府所有的住宅区，相隔仅三扇门。朱迪敲了几次琳达的前门，然后等待着。
When no one answered, she headed back home. Along the way, she glanced over at Linda's bedroom window. It was wide open and its screen had been removed. Judy went to examine it. Inside, Judy could see her sister's still figure sprawled across the bed, seemingly fast asleep. But Judy thought it was strange that Linda was lying horizontally instead of vertically with her head on the pillow. As Judy processed the scene, she was suddenly hit with the realisation of what she was seeing and let out a blood-curdling scream.
当没有人回答时，她就回家了。在路上，她瞥了一眼琳达的卧室窗户。窗户大开，纱窗已经被拆掉了。朱迪走过去查看。在里面，朱迪可以看到她姐姐静止的身影瘫在床上，似乎睡得很熟。但朱迪觉得奇怪的是，琳达是横着躺的，而不是竖着躺，头也没有枕在枕头上。当朱迪处理眼前的场景时，她突然意识到自己看到了什么，并发出了一声令人毛骨悚然的尖叫。
A maintenance worker for the housing authority heard the scream and contacted police, who arrived soon after 8.35am. They observed 31-year-old Linda Slayton's body through her bedroom window. It was clear she was deceased. The officers wandered around the property looking for a way in, but all of the doors and every other window was locked. They didn't want to disturb the scene by entering through Linda's bedroom window. But Judy Butler was distraught. Her nephews, Jeff and Tim, would be inside the apartment and she was scared they might have been hurt too.
住房管理局的一名维修工听到了尖叫声并联系了警察，警察在上午 8 点 35 分后不久赶到。他们通过卧室窗户观察到了 31 岁的琳达·斯莱顿的尸体。很明显她已经去世了。警察在房产周围徘徊寻找入口，但所有的门和每一扇窗户都锁着。他们不想通过琳达的卧室窗户进入而破坏现场。但朱迪·巴特勒心烦意乱。她的侄子杰夫和蒂姆还在公寓里，她担心他们可能也受到了伤害。
Left with no other option and facing an urgent situation, officers climbed through the open window into Linda's bedroom. The noise of their arrival woke Jeff Slayton in the living room. His younger brother, 12-year-old Tim, was asleep in the second bedroom. You need to wake up, a policeman told a confused Tim. Go outside with your brother. Tim wondered why the officer didn't mention his mother. Still wearing his pyjamas, Tim headed towards the front door. The door to his mother's room was closed, but when Tim walked by, it swung open as a police officer emerged. Tim caught a glimpse inside. His mother's
别无选择，面对紧急情况，警察爬过敞开的窗户进入了琳达的卧室。他们到来的声音惊醒了客厅里的杰夫·斯莱顿。他 12 岁的弟弟蒂姆在第二个卧室里睡觉。一名警察对困惑的蒂姆说，你需要醒醒。和你哥哥一起去外面。蒂姆纳闷警察为什么没提他母亲。蒂姆穿着睡衣走向前门。他母亲房间的门关着，但当蒂姆走过时，门开了，一名警察走了出来。蒂姆瞥了一眼里面。他母亲的
body lay awkwardly on the bed. Her dress was bunched around her abdomen, exposing both her upper and lower naked body. Her underwear was on the floor, and a wire was twisted around her bloodied neck. It was a sight that Tim would never be able to erase from his mind. 53-year-old Sergeant Edgar Pickett led the Lakeland Police Department's crime scene unit. He was a legendary fingerprint expert and only one year away from retirement when he was summoned to the Slaytons' apartment. Upon arriving, a detective remarked to Sergeant Pickett, who was African American, "...a black man don't have any business looking at a naked white woman. Despite his successful career
尸体尴尬地躺在床上。她的裙子堆在腹部周围，露出了上半身和下半身。她的内衣在地板上，一根铁丝缠绕在她血迹斑斑的脖子上。这是蒂姆永远无法从脑海中抹去的景象。53 岁的埃德加·皮克特警长领导着莱克兰警察局的犯罪现场调查组。他是一位传奇的指纹专家，在被传唤到斯莱顿家时，距离退休仅剩一年。到达后，一名侦探对身为非裔美国人的皮克特警长说：“……黑人没资格看裸体的白人女性。”尽管他事业成功
and upstanding reputation, Pickett still faced prejudice on a daily basis. Of the many deaths he'd attended, Pickett had never seen anyone treated as brutally as Linda Slayton. She had been sexually assaulted, then strangled to death with a wire coat hanger from her own closet, all while her two young sons slept close by. Aside from the displaced window screen, everything else appeared to be in place. Linda's purse was still in her room, and her jewelry lay undisturbed in a box on her dresser. There were no overt signs of a struggle, indicating the altercation had taken place entirely on the bed. Sergeant Pickett examined the entire room for evidence. Shoe prints were found on the carpet leading from the window to
且声誉卓著，皮克特每天仍面临偏见。在他处理过的众多死亡案件中，皮克特从未见过像琳达·斯莱顿这样被残酷对待的人。她遭到了性侵犯，然后被她自己衣柜里的铁丝衣架勒死，而她两个年幼的儿子就在附近睡觉。除了移位的纱窗外，其他一切似乎都在原位。琳达的钱包还在房间里，她的珠宝完好无损地放在梳妆台的盒子里。没有明显的挣扎迹象，表明冲突完全发生在床上。皮克特警长检查了整个房间寻找证据。地毯上发现了从窗户通往
the closet. Pickett also discovered a partial palm print on the windowsill. It cemented the police's theory that Linda's killer had broken into her room as opposed to being invited in. Linda's final movements were pieced together. She and her sons had only been living in the apartment for about two weeks. The previous afternoon of Thursday September 3, 15-year-old Jeff Slayton had arrived home to find there was nothing to wait. The Slaytons lived in government housing and relied on welfare. They didn't have much, but Jeff knew his mother loved her family and did the best she could. There could be two cans and a bag of flour in the cupboard and Linda would still manage to make a feast.
衣柜的鞋印。皮克特还在窗台上发现了一个部分掌纹。这巩固了警方的理论，即琳达的杀手是闯入她房间的，而不是被邀请进来的。琳达最后的行踪被拼凑起来。她和儿子们搬进这间公寓才大约两周。前一天，即 9 月 3 日星期四下午，15 岁的杰夫·斯莱顿回到家，发现没什么可吃的。斯莱顿一家住在政府住房里，依靠福利生活。他们没有多少钱，但杰夫知道他母亲爱她的家人，并尽了她最大的努力。橱柜里可能只有两个罐头和一袋面粉，琳达仍然能设法做出一顿大餐。
Her single priority was caring for her boys. Linda took Jeff and Tim out to the beach, parks and to concerts, with her goal always being to have fun. Although she struggled to make ends meet and keep her sons in line, Linda maintained a positive and happy outlook on life. When speaking with police, Jeff Slayton admitted to being somewhat rebellious and clashing with his mother. He maintained it was only ever typical teenage blow-ups and nothing serious. They'd had one such conflict on September 3 when Jeff became angry over the lack of food at home. He left the apartment and rode his bike to his maternal
她唯一的优先事项是照顾她的儿子们。琳达带杰夫和蒂姆去海滩、公园和音乐会，她的目标始终是玩得开心。尽管她努力维持生计并管教儿子，但琳达始终保持着积极快乐的生活态度。在与警方交谈时，杰夫·斯莱顿承认自己有点叛逆，曾与母亲发生冲突。他坚持认为那只是典型的青少年争吵，没什么大不了的。9 月 3 日，他们确实发生过一次这样的冲突，当时杰夫因为家里没吃的而生气。他离开了公寓，骑自行车去了他外祖父母家。
grandparents' house. They fed him and dropped him back home at around 9.30 that night. Twelve-year-old Tim Slayton had spent the latter part of the day at football practice and was given a ride home afterwards. He arrived at around 8.30pm shortly before his older brother returned. Tim then attended a get- get together at an apartment next door with his mother. A small group inside were playing cards and Linda and Tim joined in. At about 10 o'clock, Linda went back to her apartment to let Jeff know where she was, then returned to the card game. She and Tim headed home at about 11.30pm. Jeff was still up in the living room watching television. Tim went to bed as Linda washed dishes in the kitchen.
他们喂饱了他，并在那天晚上 9 点 30 分左右把他送回了家。12 岁的蒂姆·斯莱顿那天下午的大部分时间都在参加足球训练，之后搭车回家。他在晚上 8 点 30 分左右到达，就在他哥哥回来之前。蒂姆随后和母亲一起参加了隔壁公寓的一个聚会。里面的一小群人在打牌，琳达和蒂姆也加入了。大约 10 点钟，琳达回到自己的公寓告诉杰夫她在哪里，然后又回到了牌局。她和蒂姆在晚上 11 点 30 分左右回家。杰夫还在客厅看电视。蒂姆去睡觉了，琳达在厨房洗碗。
Jeff said that by now the tension between them had eased. As Linda passed him on the way to her room, he said, ''I love you mum. I'll see you tomorrow.'' Linda replied, ''I love you Jeff. Goodnight.'' Jeff said he turned the TV off at around midnight, then fell asleep. Though he described his 4 foot 10 inch mother as weighing just 100 pounds soaking wet, Jeff maintained she was tough and capable of fighting back against an attacker. Yet neither he nor Tim reported hearing anything amiss during the night. Jeff insisted that if he knew his mother was in danger, he would have rushed to help. Traces of semen found inside Linda formed the basis of a rape kit. As forensic DNA analysis was still a few years away, investigators had to narrow down potential suspects using
杰夫说，到这时他们之间的紧张关系已经缓解了。当琳达在去卧室的路上经过他身边时，他说：“妈妈，我爱你。明天见。”琳达回答说：“杰夫，我也爱你。晚安。”杰夫说他在午夜左右关掉了电视，然后睡着了。虽然他形容他身高 4 英尺 10 英寸的母亲体重只有 100 磅，但他坚持认为她很坚强，有能力反抗袭击者。然而，他和蒂姆都没有报告说在夜间听到任何异常。杰夫坚称，如果他知道母亲有危险，他会冲过去帮忙。在琳达体内发现的精液痕迹构成了强奸取证包的基础。由于法医 DNA 分析还需要几年时间，调查人员不得不通过
more traditional means. Many people were questioned, including those at the card game Linda attended hours before she was killed, and other neighbours. Police also spoke with a local construction worker named Bobby Dean who Linda had been dating. They discovered the couple had reportedly broken up two days before Linda was killed and that Linda had told others that Bobby was possessive of her. Bobby said he was at home with his sister and mother on the night of the murder. They confirmed this but couldn't be
更传统的方式缩小潜在嫌疑人的范围。许多人受到了讯问，包括琳达被杀前几小时参加牌局的人，以及其他邻居。警方还与一名琳达一直在约会的当地建筑工人鲍比·迪恩谈过。他们发现这对情侣据称在琳达被杀前两天分手了，而且琳达曾告诉别人鲍比对她有占有欲。鲍比说谋杀当晚他和他的姐姐及母亲在家。他们证实了这一点，但无法确定他在他们睡觉后是否一直待在家里。鲍比同意接受测谎仪测试。结果是不确定的。此后，他拒绝与警方合作。警方还调查了杰夫和蒂姆的父亲弗兰克·斯莱顿。琳达的姐姐朱迪形容他是一个卑鄙、一无是处的无赖。琳达和弗兰克在青少年时期相识，很早就有了两个孩子。他们结婚了，想给儿子们一个正常的家庭体验。多年来，他们四个人一直住在邻近的阿拉巴马州，但这并没有成为这对年轻父母所希望的幸福家庭。杰夫和蒂姆都记得父亲殴打母亲的时候。
certain if he stayed home after they went to bed. Bobby agreed to take a polygraph test. The results were inconclusive. After that, he refused to cooperate with police. Police also looked into Jeff and Tim's father, Frank Slayton. He was described by Linda's sister, Judy, as a mean, no-count scoundrel. Linda and Frank met as teenagers and had their two children young. They'd married, wanting to provide their sons with a proper family experience. For years, the four of them had lived together in the neighbouring state of Alabama, but it hadn't been the happy family unit the young parents had hoped for. Jeff and Tim both recalled times when their father had beaten their mother.
（注：此段落与上一段落内容有重叠，已根据原文逻辑翻译）
Frank's violence escalated when he was drunk, which was often. When Jeff was seven years old, he saw his father grab his mother by the throat, then press a gun to her head. Jeff intervened by pulling Frank away. He believed that if he hadn't done this, Frank could have pulled the trigger. In mid-1981, after nine years of marriage, Linda had filed for divorce. That was when she relocated to Lakeland with her sons for a fresh start. Given Frank Slayton's history of domestic violence and the sexual tone to Linda's murder, he became a strong suspect. Frank, who still lived in Alabama, insisted that he was at home when his ex-wife was killed. After their mother's murder, Jeff and Tim Slayton went to live with their maternal grandparents
弗兰克的暴力行为在他喝醉时会升级，这种情况经常发生。杰夫七岁时，看到父亲抓住母亲的喉咙，然后把枪抵在她的头上。杰夫通过把弗兰克拉开进行了干预。他相信如果他没有这样做，弗兰克可能会扣动扳机。1981 年年中，在九年的婚姻之后，琳达提出了离婚。那时她带着儿子们搬到了莱克兰，开始了新的生活。鉴于弗兰克·斯莱顿的家庭暴力史以及琳达谋杀案中的性色彩，他成为了一个强有力的嫌疑人。仍然住在阿拉巴马州的弗兰克坚称，他前妻被杀时他在家里。母亲被谋杀后，杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿去和他们的外祖父母住在一起，
and never set foot in their apartment again. The boys referred to the unknown killer as the Monster and lived in constant fear of him. It took time before they felt comfortable leaving their grandparents' house. The local community shared the same anxieties, believing the person responsible was among them and would strike again. The Slayton boys spent many nights sleeping in their grandparents' bed while their grandfather stayed up guarding them with a shotgun in hand. The brothers eventually returned to school, driven by advice their mum had once given them.
再也没有踏进过他们的公寓。男孩们称那个未知的杀手为“怪物”，并一直生活在对他的恐惧中。他们过了很久才觉得离开外祖父母家很自在。当地社区也有同样的焦虑，认为肇事者就在他们中间，还会再次作案。斯莱顿兄弟俩花了很多个夜晚睡在外祖父母的床上，而他们的祖父则拿着猎枪守着他们。兄弟俩最终回到了学校，这是受他们母亲曾经给他们的建议的驱动。
Keep moving forward and never give up. Tim went back to playing football, finding support among his teammates and coach. Meanwhile, Jeff Slayton faced an entirely new battle. You got big arms on you, a detective once told him, before adding. And you're strong enough to put your hands around your mum's neck and kill her. Like his father, Jeff was considered a suspect. He was the last known person to have seen his mother alive and admitted to having a heated argument with her that evening. Jeff cooperated with authorities but felt like he was being interrogated all the time. Members of the Lakeland Police Department frequently took him out of school just to question him. Jeff voluntarily took a polygraph test, which he passed. When the police wanted to perform the
继续前进，永不放弃。蒂姆回到了足球场，在队友和教练中找到了支持。与此同时，杰夫·斯莱顿面临着一场全新的战斗。一位侦探曾对他说：“你胳膊很粗，”然后补充道，“而且你足够强壮，可以把手放在你妈妈的脖子上杀了她。”像他父亲一样，杰夫被视为嫌疑人。他是最后一个被确认见到母亲活着的人，并承认那天晚上和她发生了激烈的争吵。杰夫配合当局，但感觉自己一直被审讯。莱克兰警察局的成员经常把他从学校带走，只是为了审问他。杰夫自愿接受了测谎仪测试，并顺利通过了。当警方想要再次进行
test again and floated the idea of putting Jeff under hypnosis, his grandparents stepped in and said, enough. They told investigators to leave Jeff and their family alone and find their daughter's real killer. Being treated as a suspect caused the grief-stricken Jeff even more agony. Still, he ultimately agreed to sit the second polygraph test. Once again, he passed. While police accepted there was nothing further implicating him, he remained under a cloud of suspicion. The pressure took its toll. Both Jeff and Tim dropped out of school, feeling aimless and indifferent. Jeff fell into a deep depression, during which he contemplated suicide. The pair obsessively checked the news, hoping to hear of a breakthrough in their mother's case. Yet, there was none. Every person the police interviewed had their
测试并提出让杰夫接受催眠的想法时，他的外祖父母介入并说，够了。他们告诉调查人员不要再打扰杰夫和他们的家人，去寻找他们女儿真正的杀手。被视为嫌疑人让悲痛欲绝的杰夫更加痛苦。尽管如此，他最终还是同意参加第二次测谎仪测试。他再次通过了。虽然警方承认没有进一步的证据牵连他，但他仍然笼罩在怀疑的阴影下。压力造成了损失。杰夫和蒂姆都辍学了，感到漫无目的和冷漠。杰夫陷入了深深的抑郁，期间他曾考虑自杀。两人痴迷地查看新闻，希望能听到母亲案件的突破。然而，什么都没有。警方采访的每一个人都
hand and footprints compared to those from the crime scene. None were a match and the Slayton case inevitably went cold. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Almost 20 years later in 1998, a Lakeland detective named Brad Grice was tasked with taking a fresh look at the case. He told the Ledger newspaper, They say a lot of times in a case like this, it's someone close to you who did it. He had the killer's semen sample examined by a crime lab with updated technology, permitting the extraction of a full DNA profile. Detective Grice met with Jeff and Tim Slayton,
被比对了手印和脚印与犯罪现场的样本。没有一个匹配，斯莱顿案不可避免地变成了悬案。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。近 20 年后的 1998 年，一位名叫布拉德·格莱斯的莱克兰侦探被指派重新审视此案。他告诉《莱杰报》：“在这样的案件中，人们常说，通常是身边的人干的。”他让犯罪实验室用更新的技术检查了杀手的精液样本，从而提取出了完整的 DNA 图谱。格莱斯侦探会见了杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿，
who were now in their 30s. Both voluntarily provided DNA samples. Neither matched the killer. DNA samples. Neither matched the killer. Jeff Slayton was finally vindicated and officially dismissed as a suspect. Linda's ex-husband, Frank Slayton, had cleaned up his life and was no longer drinking, instead committing to repairing his relationship with his sons. He too gave a DNA sample which ruled him out of the investigation. Other persons of interest, including Linda's ex-boyfriend, Bobby Dean, were also cleared. Detective Grice had reached a dead end. Then, in September, he received a compelling tip. The year after Linda Slayton was murdered, a 10-year-old Lakeland girl was abducted from her home. The assailant had carried the girl out of her bedroom window as she slept.
他们现在已经 30 多岁了。两人都自愿提供了 DNA 样本。没有一个与杀手匹配。杰夫·斯莱顿终于洗清了嫌疑，并被正式排除在嫌疑人之外。琳达的前夫弗兰克·斯莱顿已经改过自新，不再酗酒，而是致力于修复与儿子的关系。他也提供了 DNA 样本，排除了调查嫌疑。其他相关人员，包括琳达的前男友鲍比·迪恩，也被排除了。格莱斯侦探陷入了死胡同。然后，在 9 月，他收到了一条令人信服的线索。琳达·斯莱顿被谋杀后的第二年，一名 10 岁的莱克兰女孩从家中被绑架。袭击者在她睡觉时把她从卧室窗户抱了出去。
He then drove her around for hours, during which she was raped and strangled. Her ordeal ended at an interstate overpass. Her attacker forced her to climb over the side of the railing. As she clung desperately onto it, he pried her fingers loose, causing her to fall 24 feet to the ground. She survived and the man responsible was identified as 24-year-old Lakeland local named James Olmer. He was charged with burglary, kidnapping, and attempted murder. Ulmer was found to have a history of breaking into people's homes. On one occasion, he was caught standing over a sleeping teenage girl before fleeing. It was also believed he was responsible for the death of another girl found dead at the
然后他开车带着她转了几个小时，期间她被强奸并勒死。她的苦难在州际公路立交桥结束。她的袭击者强迫她爬过栏杆的一侧。当她绝望地抓住栏杆时，他掰开了她的手指，导致她坠落 24 英尺到地面。她幸存了下来，负责的男子被确认为一名 24 岁的莱克兰当地人，名叫詹姆斯·奥尔默。他被控入室盗窃、绑架和谋杀未遂。奥尔默被发现有闯入他人住宅的历史。有一次，他被发现站在一个熟睡的少女上方，随后逃跑。人们还认为他对另一名被发现死在
base of an overpass. Yet, Ulmer wouldn't cooperate with investigators. It was discovered that in September 1981, James Ulmer had been staying with a friend who lived in the same apartment complex as Linda Slayton. In fact, the apartment was directly across from hers, and he was there on the night she was killed. Given Linda's murder shared striking similarities to Ulmer's known offending, Detective Grice was certain he'd found Linda's killer. By the time James Ulmer was on Grice's radar, he had been dead for five years. He passed away in prison, reportedly from respiratory failure, and had been cremated. Further complicating matters was the fact that Ulmer's DNA was never collected and stored when he entered the prison system. Detective Grice spoke with the authorities who'd investigated Ulmer's previous offending. Because that case was closed, everything to do with it, including DNA samples, had been disposed of. Yet,
立交桥底部的女孩的死亡负责。然而，奥尔默不愿与调查人员合作。据发现，1981 年 9 月，詹姆斯·奥尔默一直与一位住在琳达·斯莱顿同一公寓区的朋友住在一起。事实上，那间公寓就在她的正对面，他在她被杀的那天晚上就在那里。鉴于琳达的谋杀案与奥尔默已知的犯罪行为有惊人的相似之处，格莱斯侦探确信他找到了琳达的杀手。当詹姆斯·奥尔默进入格莱斯的视线时，他已经死了五年了。他在监狱中去世，据报道死于呼吸衰竭，并已被火化。更复杂的是，奥尔默进入监狱系统时从未采集和储存过他的 DNA。格莱斯侦探与调查过奥尔默先前犯罪行为的当局进行了交谈。因为那个案件已经结案，所有与之相关的东西，包括 DNA 样本，都已被处理掉。然而，
an opportunity arose when Detective Grice convinced Ulmer's mother to provide him with a DNA sample. It could be used to determine if someone genetically linked to her had raped Linda Slayton. The results concluded that James Ulmer was not Linda's killer. This was yet another major blow for Detective Grice, who was now back where he started. He remained in contact with the Jeff and Tim Slayton, promising them that he wouldn't retire until their mother's killer was caught. He sent the killer's profile to the FBI's National DNA database, where it was continually compared against new submissions. killer's profile to the FBI's National DNA database where it was continually compared
当格莱斯侦探说服奥尔默的母亲为他提供 DNA 样本时，机会出现了。它可以用来确定与她在基因上有联系的人是否强奸了琳达·斯莱顿。结果得出结论，詹姆斯·奥尔默不是琳达的杀手。这对格莱斯侦探来说又是沉重的一击，他现在又回到了原点。他与杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿保持联系，向他们保证在抓到他们母亲的杀手之前他不会退休。他将杀手的图谱发送到了联邦调查局的国家 DNA 数据库，在那里它不断地与新的提交样本进行比对。
against new submissions. But they failed to generate a hit, and a reward for information went unclaimed. Detective Grice told the ledger, There's still hope, but man it's tough. It's frustrating when you know if you could just identify that DNA. It's like having the suspect, you just don't have the name. As years continued to pass, Detective Grice came to suspect that Linda's killer was likely deceased. After working on the case for 17 years, Brad Grice retired in 2015 for medical reasons. He'd been unable to keep his promise to the Slayton brothers and felt he'd let them down. Although Jeff and Tim were disappointed, they had no hard feelings. They just resigned to themselves to the fact that they'd likely take their last breaths
但他们未能产生匹配结果，悬赏信息也无人认领。格莱斯侦探告诉《莱杰报》：“仍然有希望，但伙计，这太难了。当你明明知道只要能识别出那个 DNA 就行，却无法获得名字时，这太令人沮丧了。”随着岁月的流逝，格莱斯侦探开始怀疑琳达的杀手可能已经去世了。在处理此案 17 年后，布拉德·格莱斯于 2015 年因健康原因退休。他没能兑现对斯莱顿兄弟的承诺，感到自己辜负了他们。虽然杰夫和蒂姆感到失望，但他们并没有怨恨。他们只是认命了，接受了他们可能在
without ever knowing who killed their mum. Jeff Slayton, quote, It's been rough my whole life not knowing who it is. Always being scared to death, I was friends with him. Always looking over my shoulder, sleeping with a switchblade knife under my pillow. Tim Slayton told the ledger, It could be that guy over there. You just don't know. By now, more than two dozen detectives had actively worked on the Slayton case. Leads were pursued interstate in Louisiana and
不知道是谁杀了他们母亲的情况下离开人世的事实。杰夫·斯莱顿说：“我这一辈子都不知道是谁干的，这种感觉太糟糕了。总是害怕得要死，我曾和他是朋友。总是回头看，睡觉时枕头下放着一把弹簧刀。”蒂姆·斯莱顿告诉《莱杰报》：“可能是那边的那个家伙。你就是不知道。”到目前为止，已有超过两打侦探积极参与过斯莱顿案。线索在路易斯安那州和
North Carolina. Jeff and Tim Slayton continued to visit and call the Lakeland Police Department so the detectives wouldn't forget them. They wound up befriending these officers, who reassured the brothers that they were still very passionate about solving the crime. reassured the brothers that they were still very passionate about solving the crime. But years continued to slip by with no arrests. Hope was fading. In 2018, Parabon NanoLabs, a company that specialises in using genetic genealogy to investigate cold cases, reached out to the Florida Department of Law Enforcement. They asked if they wanted to send the DNA from the Slayton case for further testing due to the growing success of this new form of investigation.
北卡罗来纳州进行了跨州追踪。杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿继续访问并致电莱克兰警察局，这样侦探们就不会忘记他们。他们最终与这些警官成为了朋友，警官们向兄弟俩保证，他们仍然对破案充满热情。但岁月流逝，依然没有逮捕任何人。希望正在破灭。2018 年，专门利用基因家谱调查悬案的公司 Parabon NanoLabs 联系了佛罗里达州执法部门。由于这种新型调查形式日益成功，他们询问是否愿意将斯莱顿案的 DNA 发送进行进一步测试。
38 years had passed since Linda's murder, but the rape kit had been kept in pristine condition in anticipation for a moment like this. C.C. Moore was the head of Parabon NanoLab's genetic genealogy unit. She was an expert in the field, and her team was given the Slayton case file. They began by uploading the killer's DNA into a public genealogy website called GEDmatch. Customers voluntarily submitted saliva swabs to genealogical testing companies like GEDmatch in exchange for an ancestry report. They could then connect with family members and distant relatives via online databases. Similarly, cold case investigators uploaded anonymous DNA from crime scenes to the same
琳达被谋杀已经过去了 38 年，但强奸取证包一直保持在原始状态，以期待这样的时刻。C.C. 摩尔是 Parabon NanoLab 基因家谱部门的负责人。她是该领域的专家，她的团队接手了斯莱顿案卷。他们首先将杀手的 DNA 上传到一个名为 GEDmatch 的公共家谱网站。客户自愿提交唾液拭子给像 GEDmatch 这样的家谱测试公司，以换取祖源报告。然后，他们可以通过在线数据库与家庭成员和远房亲戚建立联系。同样，悬案调查人员将犯罪现场的匿名 DNA 上传到相同的
databases, but with the intention of identifying suspects through their familial lineage. This method was used to help capture the Golden State Killer a year prior, as covered in episode 53 of Case File. Unsurprisingly, Linda Slayton's killer hadn't uploaded his DNA to GEDmatch. But genealogist C.C. Moore and her team constructed a family tree based on his distant relatives who had. They filled in the gaps using birth certificates, marriage licenses, obituaries and social media. It only took Moore's team a weekend to uncover three genetic networks, individual branches
数据库，但目的是通过家族血统识别嫌疑人。这种方法曾在一年前帮助抓获了“金州杀手”，正如 Case File 第 53 集所报道的那样。不出所料，琳达·斯莱顿的杀手并没有将他的 DNA 上传到 GEDmatch。但家谱学家 C.C. 摩尔和她的团队根据上传了 DNA 的远房亲戚构建了一棵家谱树。他们利用出生证明、结婚证、讣告和社交媒体填补了空白。摩尔的团队只用了一个周末就发现了三个遗传网络，即
that converged into one single family. The family only had one son and he had roots in Lakeland in 1981. C.C. Moore was highly confident he was the DNA contributor. Tim Slayton's favourite sport was American football. Weeks after his mother was killed, 14-year-old Tim returned to the game, finding comfort among his teammates. One of his biggest supporters was his team's assistant coach, a 20-year-old man affectionately called Coach Joe. Coach Joe's full name was Joseph Mills. When he wasn't volunteering with Lakeland's youth football program, Mills worked at a dairy warehouse. He knew Linda Slayton was a single mum who couldn't afford a car and helped her out by
汇聚成一个单一家庭的各个分支。这个家庭只有一个儿子，他在 1981 年在莱克兰有根基。C.C. 摩尔非常有信心他就是 DNA 贡献者。蒂姆·斯莱顿最喜欢的运动是美式足球。母亲被杀几周后，14 岁的蒂姆回到了比赛中，在队友中找到了安慰。他最大的支持者之一是球队的助理教练，一个 20 岁的年轻人，被亲切地称为“乔教练”。乔教练的全名是约瑟夫·米尔斯。当他不为莱克兰的青年足球项目做志愿者时，米尔斯在一家乳制品仓库工作。他知道琳达·斯莱顿是一位买不起车的单亲妈妈，并帮助她
giving Tim rides to and from practice. In fact, he had picked up Tim and driven him home on the very day Linda Slayton was later killed. The next day, police interviewed Mills briefly over the phone. He wasn't questioned any further, meaning he'd failed to register on their radar. It wouldn't have helped that those who knew him would have provided glowing character references. When genealogist C.C. Moore was tracing Linda Slayton's killer in 2019, all branches led to Joseph Mills. Better yet, he was still alive. The now 58-year-old lived on Bailey Road, 30 minutes from the crime scene. It was the same place he'd lived in 1981. Mills had changed a lot since then. He'd gone bald and his facial hair had greyed. He was still married to the same woman and not only did he have children of his own, but grandchildren as well.
接送蒂姆往返训练。事实上，就在琳达·斯莱顿后来被杀的那天，他接了蒂姆并开车送他回家。第二天，警方通过电话简短地采访了米尔斯。他没有受到进一步的讯问，这意味着他没有进入他们的视线。那些认识他的人提供的溢美之词对他也没什么帮助。当家谱学家 C.C. 摩尔在 2019 年追踪琳达·斯莱顿的杀手时，所有的分支都指向了约瑟夫·米尔斯。更好的是，他还活着。现年 58 岁的他住在距离犯罪现场 30 分钟路程的贝利路。那是他 1981 年居住的同一个地方。米尔斯从那时起改变了很多。他秃顶了，面部毛发也变灰了。他仍然和同一个女人结婚，不仅有自己的孩子，还有孙辈。
Over the past three decades Mills had taken on a variety of jobs. Now he was running his own cleaning business. Mills was also known to police. In 1984, he had been convicted of grand theft after forging a will. He didn't go to prison, but his handprints were taken and kept on file. These were compared to the partial palm print lifted from Linda Slayton's windowsill. It was a match. The final piece of the puzzle was comparing Joseph Mills' DNA to that of Linda's killer. Investigators covertly surveilled Mills for several weekends, waiting for an opportunity to discreetly obtain a sample of his DNA. This would be done by picking up something he discarded,
在过去的三十年里，米尔斯从事过各种工作。现在他经营着自己的清洁公司。米尔斯也为警方所知。1984 年，他因伪造遗嘱被判犯有重大盗窃罪。他没有入狱，但他的手印被采集并存档。这些手印与从琳达·斯莱顿窗台上提取的部分掌纹进行了比对。匹配成功。拼图的最后一块是将约瑟夫·米尔斯的 DNA 与琳达杀手的 DNA 进行比对。调查人员在几个周末秘密监视米尔斯，等待机会悄悄获取他的 DNA 样本。这可以通过捡起他丢弃的东西来完成，
like a tissue or coffee cup. When this approach failed, investigators secretly seized Mills' trash from the curb outside his home. After digging through the garbage bags, they uncovered a piece of used medical adhesive tape for a colostomy bag. A 2013 photograph on Mills' Facebook page showed he had a colostomy bag. The tape was most certainly his, but to be sure, officers also collected two cotton swabs and a plastic spoon from the trash. All the items were sent off for testing. 11 days later, the results were in. Joseph Mills' DNA matched the DNA of Linda Slayton's killer. matched the DNA of Linda Slayton's killer.
比如纸巾或咖啡杯。当这种方法失败时，调查人员秘密从他家门外的路边扣押了米尔斯的垃圾。在翻找垃圾袋后，他们发现了一块用于造口袋的用过的医用胶带。米尔斯 Facebook 页面上 2013 年的一张照片显示他有一个造口袋。胶带肯定是他的，但为了确定，警官们还从垃圾中收集了两根棉签和一把塑料勺子。所有物品都被送去测试。11 天后，结果出来了。约瑟夫·米尔斯的 DNA 与琳达·斯莱顿杀手的 DNA 匹配。
Following this, police spoke with the Joseph Mills at his home. He said he didn't remember Linda Slayton or her murder. He was then shown photographs of Linda and her two sons. This prompted Mills to claim he did remember them but hadn't known Linda personally. He also said that he didn't recall coaching Tim Slayton or that he'd dropped him off at the Slaytons' home the night Linda was killed. Eight days later, on Thursday December 12, 2019, police met with Mills again and placed him under arrest. He didn't seem surprised and never asked why. Instead, he was unusually calm and showed no emotion. During a subsequent police interview, Mills was now willing to open up about his history with Tim Slayton. He asserted that whenever he dropped Tim off at home after practice,
此后，警方在他家中与约瑟夫·米尔斯进行了交谈。他说他不记得琳达·斯莱顿或她的谋杀案。然后他被展示了琳达和她两个儿子的照片。这促使米尔斯声称他确实记得他们，但不认识琳达本人。他还说，他不记得曾执教过蒂姆·斯莱顿，也不记得在琳达被杀的那天晚上送他回斯莱顿家。八天后，即 2019 年 12 月 12 日星期四，警方再次与米尔斯会面并将他逮捕。他看起来并不惊讶，也从未问过为什么。相反，他异常冷静，没有表现出任何情绪。在随后的警方采访中，米尔斯现在愿意谈论他与蒂姆·斯莱顿的往事。他断言，每当他在训练后送蒂姆回家时，
he stayed in his car. Mills maintained that he had never been inside the Slayton home at any time, for any reason. What we have tells us a different story, a detective responded, before adding, you were in that apartment. Mills was informed that evidence placed him in Linda Slayton's bedroom, with one detective remarking, it's been 38 years and I'm sure you go to bed every night thinking about this. Mills remained indignant, reiterating that he had never been inside the apartment. Upon learning that his handprints and DNA were found at the crime scene, Mills changed his story again. He said that he had met Linda for the first time on Thursday September 3, 1981 when he
他都待在车里。米尔斯坚称他从未在任何时间、以任何理由进入过斯莱顿家。一名侦探回答说：“我们掌握的情况告诉我们一个不同的故事，”然后补充道，“你就在那间公寓里。”米尔斯被告知证据将他置于琳达·斯莱顿的卧室中，一名侦探评论道：“已经 38 年了，我相信你每天晚上睡觉时都会想到这件事。”米尔斯仍然愤愤不平，重申他从未进入过那间公寓。在得知他的手印和 DNA 在犯罪现场被发现后，米尔斯再次改变了他的说法。他说他是在 1981 年 9 月 3 日星期四第一次见到琳达的，当时他
dropped Tim home. Linda approached Mills' car to thank him. According to Mills, Linda gave him an open invitation to stop by for, quote, a good time. Mills took her up on her offer that night. He entered her bedroom through her unlocked window. He entered her bedroom through her unlocked window. Linda was lying on her bed waiting for him. Mills claimed that the wire coat hanger was already around her neck and she asked him to tighten it for her pleasure. They had consensual sex that Mills described as wild, during which she twisted the wire tighter and tighter as per Linda's wishes. Linda then lost consciousness. After finishing, Mills left back out the window without checking to see if Linda
送蒂姆回家。琳达走近米尔斯的车表示感谢。据米尔斯说，琳达给了他一个公开邀请，让他顺便过来“玩玩”。米尔斯那天晚上接受了她的提议。他通过她未锁的窗户进入了她的卧室。琳达躺在床上等着他。米尔斯声称铁丝衣架已经缠在她的脖子上，她要求他为了她的快感把它勒紧。他们进行了米尔斯描述为“狂野”的自愿性行为，期间她按照琳达的意愿把铁丝越拧越紧。琳达随后失去了知觉。结束后，米尔斯从窗户离开，没有检查琳达
had woken up. He claimed that he'd only learnt that she'd died when detectives questioned him about it later. Linda's autopsy results determined her injuries were inconsistent with consensual sex. There were even self-sustained claw marks to her neck consistent with her struggling to remove the wire. When detectives pointed out how deep the hanger was embedded in Linda's skin, Mills maintained, quote, it was a game. Detectives were unconvinced. They were certain that after dropping Tim Slayton home, Joseph Mills returned to the apartment later, having made the decision to rape Linda. He broke in through her bedroom window at around 9pm during a brief period of time when no one was home. Mills then lay in wait in Linda's bedroom, likely hiding in the closet,
是否醒来。他声称他只是在后来侦探询问他时才知道她已经死了。琳达的尸检结果确定她的伤势与自愿性行为不符。她的脖子上甚至有她自己抓出的抓痕，这与她挣扎着想取下铁丝的情况一致。当侦探指出衣架嵌入琳达皮肤有多深时，米尔斯坚持说：“那是个游戏。”侦探们并不相信。他们确信在送蒂姆·斯莱顿回家后，约瑟夫·米尔斯后来回到了公寓，决定强奸琳达。他在晚上 9 点左右，在没人家的短暂时间内，通过她的卧室窗户闯入。米尔斯随后潜伏在琳达的卧室里，很可能躲在衣柜里，
where he collected the wire hanger. When Linda retired for bed that night, she walked into her room and closed the door, oblivious that Mills was already in there waiting for her. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Joseph Mills was charged with burglary, sexual battery and first degree murder. Jeff and Tim Slayton were stunned to learn a trusted family friend had killed their mother. The thought that Coach Joe could be responsible had never even crossed their minds. They hoped to see Mills face trial, explain himself on the stand and face the death penalty. After being advised by his attorney that
在那里他收集了铁丝衣架。那天晚上琳达去睡觉时，她走进房间并关上了门，完全不知道米尔斯已经在里面等着她了。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。约瑟夫·米尔斯被控入室盗窃、性暴力和一级谋杀罪。杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿得知一位受信任的家庭朋友杀害了他们的母亲时感到震惊。乔教练可能要负责的想法甚至从未出现在他们的脑海中。他们希望看到米尔斯接受审判，在证人席上解释自己并面临死刑。在被他的律师告知
it was in his best interest to plead guilty to all charges, Mills did so. Yet, he still refused to admit to killing Linda Slayton. Jeff and Tim Slayton were in court during sentencing in February 2022 surrounded by supportive friends and family. They were both given the opportunity to speak. Jeff turned to Mills and tearfully asked over and over, sometimes yelling, Jeff turned to Mills and tearfully asked over and over, sometimes yelling, Why? I just want to know why, Joe. Why'd you take my mama from me? I loved my mama. We were happy. I hate you. You can't die and burn in hell fast enough for me. Mills remained silent and stone-faced in response. Linda's sister, Judy Butler, was met with the same reaction when she asked Mills, Do you have any soul? Do you have any remorse?
对所有指控认罪符合他的最大利益后，米尔斯照做了。然而，他仍然拒绝承认杀害了琳达·斯莱顿。杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿在 2022 年 2 月的量刑听证会上出庭，周围是支持他们的朋友和家人。他们都有机会发言。杰夫转向米尔斯，含泪一遍又一遍地问，有时是大喊：“为什么？我只想知道为什么，乔。你为什么要从我身边夺走我的妈妈？我爱我的妈妈。我们很幸福。我恨你。你死后下地狱对我来说都不够快。”米尔斯保持沉默，面无表情地回应。琳达的姐姐朱迪·巴特勒在问米尔斯“你有灵魂吗？你有悔意吗？”时也得到了同样的反应。
The court also heard from Linda's grandchildren who never got to meet her. When the defendant was given the chance to speak, he told the court, I am a good person. I'm not that person that they're painting me out to be. He explained that he owned a successful business in which he gave people chances. The judge was unmoved by these claims. He sentenced Joseph Mills to life in prison without the possibility of parole. A tearful Jeff Slayton told the media outside court,
法庭还听取了琳达从未见过面的孙辈的陈述。当被告有机会发言时，他告诉法庭：“我是一个好人。我不是他们描绘的那种人。”他解释说他拥有一家成功的企业，在企业里他给了人们机会。法官对这些说法无动于衷。他判处约瑟夫·米尔斯终身监禁，不得假释。含泪的杰夫·斯莱顿在法庭外告诉媒体：
I don't know if there's anything such as closure, but it has been easier knowing he's locked up." Tim Slayton added, "...it's not over in the sense cause he's still walking and my mum's not." Detective Brad Grice was one of the dozens of detectives who investigated the Slayton case over the near 40 years it went unsolved. He had worked on it for 17 of those years, but had to retire before it was solved. When Joseph Mills was identified as the killer, Detective Grice blamed himself for not having identified him sooner. The Slayton brothers felt differently. They
“我不知道是否有什么所谓的了结，但知道他被关起来了，感觉轻松了一些。”蒂姆·斯莱顿补充道：“……这并没有结束，因为他还活着，而我妈妈不在了。”布拉德·格莱斯侦探是在近 40 年悬案期间调查斯莱顿案的数十名侦探之一。他为此工作了 17 年，但在案件解决前不得不退休。当约瑟夫·米尔斯被确认为杀手时，格莱斯侦探责怪自己没有早点认出他。斯莱顿兄弟有不同的看法。他们
expressed gratitude to all those who worked to find their mother's killer, including Detective Grice, whom they considered a friend. In fact, Jeff was so appreciative of the detective's effort, he named one of his sons after him. The Slayton brothers held the same regard for Sergeant Edgar Pickett, who uncovered the killer's palm print on Linda's bedroom windowsill. This evidence helped solidify Joseph Mills' guilt. By the time Jeff and Tim were able to meet Pickett and thank him, he was 94 years old. were able to meet Pickett and thank him, he was 94 years old. It was a case Pickett had never forgotten. Once his job at the crime scene was over, his mind kept returning to the two Slayton boys. Pickett himself had children and was driven to solve Linda's murder to give her son's closure.
对所有为寻找他们母亲的杀手而工作的人表示感谢，包括他们视为朋友的格莱斯侦探。事实上，杰夫非常感激这位侦探的努力，他以他的名字命名了自己的一个儿子。斯莱顿兄弟对埃德加·皮克特警长也怀有同样的敬意，正是他发现了琳达卧室窗台上的杀手掌纹。这一证据有助于巩固约瑟夫·米尔斯的罪行。当杰夫和蒂姆能够见到皮克特并感谢他时，他已经 94 岁了。这是一个皮克特从未忘记的案件。一旦他在犯罪现场的工作结束，他的思绪就会不断回到两个斯莱顿男孩身上。皮克特自己也有孩子，他致力于解决琳达的谋杀案，以给她的儿子们一个了结。
Despite his involvement in the investigation, Pickett had never heard the name Joseph Mills and was unaware that the young man had been questioned early on in the investigation. In fact, Pickett revealed that he had been told to compare the palm print to a number of black men following reports of suspicious activity by black individuals at the time. Pickett, who was African American himself, admitted that the prejudice of his white colleagues influenced his own mindset. Random black men were questioned and fingerprinted en masse. Meanwhile, the white football coach who'd been at the Slayton home the night Linda was murdered was completely overlooked. Pickett admitted that he didn't handle the case like he should have,
尽管皮克特参与了调查，但他从未听说过约瑟夫·米尔斯这个名字，也不知道这个年轻人早在调查初期就曾被问话。事实上，皮克特透露，由于当时有关于黑人可疑活动的报告，他曾被告知将掌纹与多名黑人进行比对。皮克特本人也是非裔美国人，他承认白人同事的偏见影响了他自己的心态。当时，随机的黑人被大规模地传唤并采集指纹。与此同时，案发当晚在斯莱顿家中的白人橄榄球教练却完全被忽视了。皮克特承认他处理此案的方式不当，
and it had been on his conscience ever since. Despite this, case detectives maintained that Joseph Mills didn't slip through the cracks. Genealogist C.C. Moore, who had worked on hundreds of cases and solved more than 50 using genetic genealogy, said that Linda Slaytons made her the angriest because the killer targeted Linda while her children slept nearby. When Joseph Mills blamed Linda, denigrating her and making her look bad in front of her own children, Moore's disgust grew further. C.C. Moore expressed gratitude to the original crime scene investigators, saying, "...at the time this crime was committed, they didn't even know DNA was going to be used in criminal investigations.
这让他一直心怀愧疚。尽管如此，案件侦探坚称约瑟夫·米尔斯并没有成为漏网之鱼。基因学家C.C.摩尔曾处理过数百起案件，并利用基因谱系学解决了50多起案件。她说，琳达·斯莱顿案让她最愤怒，因为凶手在琳达的孩子们在附近熟睡时对她下手。当约瑟夫·米尔斯指责琳达，在她的孩子面前诋毁她并抹黑她时，摩尔的厌恶感进一步加深。C.C.摩尔对最初的犯罪现场调查人员表示感谢，她说：“……在犯罪发生时，他们甚至不知道DNA会被用于刑事调查。
And so the fact they collected that and then it was stored responsibly and carefully all these years by that department is so important. If that hadn't happened, we couldn't have done our work. In May 2019, Jetmatch, the DNA database used to help solve the Slayton case, changed its privacy rules. It is now much more difficult to solve cold cases using this method. C.C. Moore said, Whatever one thinks about this decision, it is inarguably a setback for justice, victims, and their families. Jeff and Tim Slayton have come to terms with the Joseph Mills' outcome, but still lack closure.
因此，他们收集了这些证据，并且多年来由该部门负责任地妥善保存，这一点至关重要。如果不是这样，我们就无法开展工作。2019年5月，用于协助解决斯莱顿案的DNA数据库Jetmatch更改了其隐私规则。现在，使用这种方法解决悬案变得困难得多。C.C.摩尔说，无论人们对这一决定有何看法，这无疑是对正义、受害者及其家属的一次挫折。杰夫和蒂姆·斯莱顿已经接受了约瑟夫·米尔斯案的结果，但仍未感到释怀。
It stung them that he was able to live a full life and raise a family for four decades. The brothers felt they were handed a far harsher sentence than he was as they had to grow up and live without their mother. Still, they harboured no resentment towards law enforcement for taking so long to apprehend Mills, with Tim Slayton explaining, I know it's a lot of hard work behind the scenes that people don't see that goes on. it's a lot of hard work behind the scenes that people don't see that goes on. You know, what they do, the hours upon hours they put in. I mean, you could get mad, but only so much could be done in a day. The brothers have said that they couldn't have survived their ordeal without each other. Over the years, they stayed close, living just a few
让他能够过上完整的生活并抚养家庭四十年，这让他们感到痛苦。兄弟俩觉得他们受到的惩罚比他严厉得多，因为他们必须在没有母亲的情况下长大成人。尽管如此，他们对执法部门花了这么长时间才逮捕米尔斯并没有怨恨，蒂姆·斯莱顿解释说：“我知道幕后有很多人们看不到的艰苦工作。你知道，他们所做的事情，他们投入的无数个小时。我的意思是，你可能会生气，但一天之内能做的事情毕竟有限。”兄弟俩说，如果没有彼此，他们无法度过那段艰难的岁月。多年来，他们一直保持亲密，住得只有几
miles apart and sharing the same hobbies so they could constantly be in each other's lives. They visited their mother's graveside often and lit a candle every year on the anniversary of her murder. Jeff Slayton, quote, "...my mum, she's looking down on us and would want us to live our lives and do good. I want to make her proud. After his mother's murder, Tim Slayton cried for two weeks straight. Then he stopped and has been unable to cry since. Then he stopped and has been unable to cry since. Some have seen his inability to cry as cold, but it's as though Tim ran out of tears. Following Linda's death, Joseph Mills continued to act as a friend to Tim. He continued picking him up and dropping him off at football practice.
英里远，并有着相同的爱好，这样他们就能时刻陪伴在彼此的生活中。他们经常去母亲的墓前祭拜，并在她遇害周年纪念日每年点燃一支蜡烛。杰夫·斯莱顿说：“……我的妈妈，她在注视着我们，她会希望我们过好自己的生活，多做善事。我想让她为我感到骄傲。”母亲遇害后，蒂姆·斯莱顿连续哭了两个星期。然后他停了下来，从此再也无法流泪。有些人认为他无法流泪是因为冷漠，但其实就像是蒂姆的眼泪流干了。琳达去世后，约瑟夫·米尔斯继续扮演蒂姆朋友的角色。他继续接送他去参加橄榄球训练。
During these trips, Mills asked about Linda's case and what leads police were looking into. Tim didn't know it at the time, but his mum's killer was using him to scope out the ongoing investigation. Then, a month after Linda's murder, Mills had a team photo taken. In it, Tim and his teammates stand side by side in their white jerseys. Directly behind Tim was Coach Joe. Tim saw his coach organising this as a show of solidarity and support. He appreciated the photo so much that he hung it up in his bedroom at his grandparents' home. He had no clue that he was looking at the face of his mother's killer daily. The photo was once a source of pride for Tim, but now it disgusts him. He sees it as proof of how cold-hearted Joseph Mills was. Worse still were the haunting memories of seeing his mother's brutalised and naked body in situ. Tim Slayton, quote,
在这些行程中，米尔斯询问琳达案件的情况以及警方正在调查的线索。蒂姆当时并不知道，他母亲的凶手正在利用他来打探调查进展。后来，在琳达遇害一个月后，米尔斯拍了一张球队合影。照片中，蒂姆和队友们穿着白色球衣并排站立。蒂姆的正后方是乔教练。蒂姆认为教练组织这次拍照是为了表达团结和支持。他非常珍视这张照片，把它挂在祖父母家卧室的墙上。他根本不知道自己每天都在看着母亲凶手的脸。这张照片曾经是蒂姆的骄傲，但现在却让他感到恶心。他将其视为约瑟夫·米尔斯冷酷无情的证据。更糟糕的是，他脑海中挥之不去的记忆是看到母亲赤裸且惨遭蹂躏的尸体。蒂姆·斯莱顿说，
"...I've seen the crime scene. It's in my head every day. I've got to live with that." Unlike his younger brother, Jeff Slayton cries all the time. He tells himself he won't, but tears fall whenever he starts thinking about his mother. Speaking with the journalist Paul Azan about Joseph Mills, Jeff said tearfully, about Joseph Mills, Jeff said tearfully, the day he murdered my mum, he murdered my childhood. It was the last day me and my brother were kids. Jeff harbours immense guilt, telling filmmakers of the CBS series The Betrayal of Linda Slayton, I would have died that night trying to save my mum. I mean, we're right there in the house. But I didn't hear nothing. How could you not hear something like that? It's so hard to live with that." In order to explain why he and Tim didn't hear the attack, Jeff believes that Joseph
“……我见过犯罪现场。它每天都在我脑海里。我必须带着这个活下去。”与弟弟不同，杰夫·斯莱顿总是哭个不停。他告诉自己不要哭，但每当想到母亲时，眼泪就会流下来。在与记者保罗·阿赞谈论约瑟夫·米尔斯时，杰夫含泪说道：“他谋杀我妈妈的那天，也谋杀了我童年。那是我和弟弟作为孩子度过的最后一天。”杰夫怀有巨大的负罪感，他告诉CBS系列纪录片《琳达·斯莱顿的背叛》的制片人：“那天晚上我本会为了救妈妈而死。我的意思是，我们就住在房子里。但我什么都没听到。怎么可能听不到那样的动静？带着这种愧疚生活太难了。”为了解释为什么他和蒂姆没有听到袭击声，杰夫认为约瑟夫
Mills threatened their mother to keep quiet or else he'd hurt her children. Jeff Slayton, quote, "...so she saved us is the way we look at it. She could have screamed and yelled like a lot of people would have done if you're in that position, but again, she was looking out for us. That was probably the last thing on her mind. Was us. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
米尔斯威胁了他们的母亲，让她保持安静，否则就会伤害她的孩子。杰夫·斯莱顿说：“……所以我们认为她是救了我们。如果换作别人处在那种位置，可能会大声尖叫，但她当时想到的还是我们。那可能是她脑海中最后一件想到的事。就是我们。”音乐 本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。